welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm Benjamin Dixon filling in for David
while he's away on vacation thanks so
much for having me yesterday and we're
having an I would say a good time today
but the stories today are so heavy this
this particular story has messing with
me since since I read it NBC is
reporting that immigrants were forced
into solitary confinement for being
disabled mentally ill our game and I
just want to read a couple of the stats
that embassy reported on six detainees
committed suicide while in confinement
one detainee was held in solitary for 11
months and another for over a year some
390 days in confinement the
whistleblower in this case stated that
ice claims ice immigrations custom
enforcement claims that they only use
this as a last resort but she witnessed
how this was used as a first resort and
how it was used on people with mental
illnesses and in many cases they were
merely acting out based on their mental
illness and yet instead of getting them
treatment medication to getting them to
see a doctor or whatever their
particular case required they put them
in solitary confinement they claimed
that it's for safety reasons but in many
cases the detainees were acting out
simply based on their illnesses and
somebody pray tell please tell me what
safety reasons are you going to put a
person into solitary confinement because
they're gay ice is literally actually
before I even finish that sentence I
have to back up some of this took place
underneath the Obama administration it's
been happening for the last five years
so for five years we have been putting
people into solitary confinement leading
to the suicide of a
least six detainees that we know of and
I'm sure there are more than that at
this point all because we have this
Fedotov we feta size we have this this
inordinate fear of not even a fear
hatred of immigrants and we we do have
we do it's almost like a fetish that we
have to that we have to capture them and
we have to punish them and we have to
make them go through every terrible
thing we can imagine just so that they
can be worthy enough to begin the
process of becoming a citizen or a
resident so this has been happening
longer than the Trump administration but
the very worst has been happening under
the Trump administration because while
ice needs to be abolished and and Barack
Obama was the reporter in chief there's
an element to this a level of
insidiousness and a level of cruelty
that is attached to this because of the
nature of this president and because of
the nature of the people he surrounds
himself with like Steven Miller who have
a an obscene hatred for immigrants and
have this this laser-like target on the
backs of every brown immigrant that
comes to this country and they enjoy
this cruelty or as Adam sir of the the I
believe the Atlantic says the cruelty is
the point now what I was going to say a
few moments ago is ice is truly acting
out on all of America's fascistic
tendencies I mean we like to think of
ourselves as home with a free in the
land of the brave and whatever I
probably mixed that up whatever we like
to think of ourselves in that way but in
all actuality throughout American
history we have been brutal
authoritarian I mean fascistic we have
interned people we started this country
on genocide we
this country through slave labor we we
exacerbated the the the criminalization
and the other vacation of black people
through Jim Crow and all the way along
the line we in turn Japanese people
doing World War two I mean we have there
are so many crimes that show you what
America really is and now to add on top
of all that we are treating people
lobbying them into concentration camps
for lack of a better word based on the
fact that they're mentally ill they're
disabled or they're gay I mean this this
we don't like to draw comparisons with
Adolf Hitler and we don't like to
compare anything to the Holocaust
rightly so but this reminds me of a
playbook straight out of my account like
this is a straight out of Nazi playbook
of purging
I mean how else do you how else can you
see this it's almost like ice like I was
laughing about this earlier but it's
like we just need to put an S at the end
of ice and go ahead and call them Isis
because of things like this because of
the number of people who are dying in
their custody because of the way they're
carrying out their policies because of
the way they are that they're draconian
fashion which they're like they're
cutthroat their cruelty their cruelty
for no reason no justifiable reason none
none whatsoever I I don't know how this
story's gonna end I don't know what the
result of this whistleblower is going to
be but one thing I can tell you for
certain it shines a light on the fact
that this country that we like to claim
is so beautiful and this country that we
like to claim is so free has at its core
a fascistic leaning that if we're not
careful we will be in a nation that we
never thought this nation could be
today's sponsor is Skillshare and i'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to Skillshare when
you click the link underneath this video
skill shares the site that offers over
25,000 on
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]